in our continuing series tonight
whatever happened to catching up with
the effort to catch some runaways
Linda Vaughn asked on Facebook whatever
happened to the Afghan soldiers missing
in the US seven went missing from their
bases in October of 2016 and there were
there were more prior to that some were
from Fort Benning and some were from
Fort Gordon just to name a couple of the
bases well tonight Linda national
security correspondent Jennifer Griffin
has some answers they came to America to
hone their military skills what happened
once they got here is raising questions
152 Afghan sent for training since 2005
went AWOL by far the largest percentage
of military recruits from any one
country to disappear that according to
an explosive Special Inspector General
report last October six months later Fox
News has learned an additional 27 Afghan
troops training at military bases across
the u.s. ran away where did they go and
what happened to them some escaped up
north to Canada 164 were caught most of
those sent back to Afghanistan but nine
Afghan soldiers remain at large
according to new numbers provided by the
Pentagon Democratic Senator Claire
McCaskill of Missouri wrote to defense
secretary Jim mattis demanding answers
since 11 Afghan trainees ran from Fort
Leonard Wood in the Senators home state
the Department of Homeland Security has
located all 11 last year saw a jump and
those who tried to escape in the US
following a spike in violence in
Afghanistan and fear the US would pull
out leaving the country to be overrun by
the Taliban we weren't giving them
proper support and they were offered the
perfect opportunity to be safe and
secure somewhere else 2,750 Afghan
soldiers have received us-based training
the Afghan embassy has taken measures to
ensure the Afghan trainees return to
jobs in Kabul in the past the Afghan
military would fill their positions
while they were gone and the Taliban
would threaten their fan
those who perhaps did dessert is
negligible to begin with but we're
ensuring we're doing everything we we
can to ensure that even that does not
happen the Pentagon has until March 15th
to respond to the Special Inspector
General for Afghan reconstruction 'he's
explosive report about what the
Department of Defense and ice are doing
to keep these Afghan officers from going
AWOL and finding those who are still at
large
Brett Jennifer Griffin at the Pentagon
Jennifer thank you